[Music]
let's go to is it judea judea
joe jude judea
judea in oklahom oakland oklahoma in
oakland california
today i'm struggling with the old with
the old reading today sorry about that
how are you no worries i'm great how are
you excellent okay say it for me judea
what's the origin of that name it's
beautiful it
thank you it's a um i'm not jewish but
it is a jewish name yes um you can find
it in the bible actually in the
christmas
story oh my gosh that was a great flex
where's your name from the bible
well done
i'm from scripture where are you from my
name is another term for toilet so
thanks for bringing that up judea much
appreciated
all right so what's up how can i help
i've had attention issues ever since i
can remember
i have no idea what that's like continue
oh man
okay so tell me about them
um so it was a really big stressor in my
in my family's life all growing up and i
feel like it still haunts me to this day
i'm now an adult with my dream job and
i'm struggling harder than ever to keep
up with my co-workers my current
therapist suggests i consider medication
or seeking a diagnosis for something
like adult adhd but i'm afraid it will
hurt me
um i wanted to get a second opinion but
it's still something that i'm open to
considering gotcha okay
so when you say you've got attention
challenges
tell me what that means give me some
paint me a real picture of what that
looks like
that means i'll start on a task or i'll
start trying to listen to something
for example like when i was a kid in
class um i'd maybe listen for about five
minutes and then
you're going to feel like something
would yep then i was gone something
would be difficult and my mind would
just wander i never really had the
hyperactivity issue but i could sit
there and look like i was paying
attention but it's common with
especially young young girls
um
they look like they are plugged in and
their minds are off to the races boys
yeah
and again i don't unnecessarily gender
it but the data tells me boys will bang
their heads on things and
but girls can be equally out too
um
have you over the course of your
lifetime or working with your counselor
have you identified some places where
your brain checks out for you
um i think a few mostly with academic
type pursuits so when i'm trying to
learn a new skill at work or something
that seems really complicated
it's as if i just say i'm out i can't do
this okay
what is your brain protecting you from
there
um
i'm a bit of a perfectionist i
definitely have a fear of failure i've
been working really hard on that where
does that come from who gave you that
i don't
i don't know um i wouldn't say my family
is super perfectionistic but my mom was
really hard on herself when she was
growing up to make sure that she got
good grades and i think
um
because she came from kind of a
difficult situation i think she was
always worried that
um
the same would happen to me but if i
wasn't able to pay attention and do well
in school then
um i wouldn't be able to get a good job
as an adult
how was your parents marriage growing up
fantastic they were always um
they gave me a really good picture of
what a great marriage should be like
awesome so what about my dating life now
i look for people who
are kind like my dad is awesome awesome
what about um
what about brothers and sisters
i've got a younger brother and um he
tells me that he's had some attention
issues too yeah
um so
you may have heard this show we think we
did a whole episode on this maybe a year
and a half ago or so
um gabor mate
m-a-t-e
wrote a book i think it's called
scattered
um i think that's it is that it
it's the what i consider the masterpiece
on
adhd
attention challenges
and so before i did anything i would
read that book
and when i say it's a masterpiece i mean
i sat there and wept through the book
and then i gave it to my wife because
i've i hadn't had my life peeled back
and i've read you name it the
i've read every book on adhd
just trying to figure out where is this
often
it stems from
some sort of childhood chaos
okay or some sort of trying to connect
relationally go ahead
there was a period of time um right
after 9 11 i think in the years
following where um my mom was military
so
there was kind of this she was reserves
but there was kind of this understanding
that
there could be a time when mom will get
called to go overseas
um and i think that might have had
something to do with it i think maybe i
would
um
like i was really little when they kind
of showed the attacks over television so
as a little kid that's i mean as anyone
at that time that's really traumatic
yeah and they've even traced some of
this back to maternal
stress like prenatally like when
somebody's pregnant so if your mom's in
the military and she's pregnant or she's
trying to figure out what she's gonna do
there's so much there
that um
all that to say is this often the
attention issues are a result of
your body trying to make sense of chaos
and i live with this every single day of
my life and so i'm telling i'm speaking
as to somebody you and i are in the same
club here okay
okay
um
i'm not opposed to medication
but when it comes to adhd man i want to
see somebody go to the ends of the earth
uh and so when it whenever
mainly because you get on a stimulant
track and there's no way off
the only move is to increase stimulants
for the rest of your life and the
downstream effects of some of those
things are
dramatic
and that's what i'm afraid of but it
also feels like that i've tried
everything else i feel like i've tried
changing my diet i've tried
just trying to white knuckle it through
times when i'm having a hard time paying
attention what brings you peace
i think knowing that
i'm capable of accomplishing the task at
hand
or knowing that i'm capable of taking
care of myself nope not that
what brings you peace
are you dating somebody now
yeah do you like them
yeah
like you like like them or just like
yeah
i i like like him quite a bit and um so
far it's been a very good relationship
how how long
uh really only about eight months so
it's still kind of in the beginning
stages that's a thousand years in dating
world these days so good for you
so thank you
is there moments when y'all are together
and he's either holding you or you're
holding hands and your feet are propped
up
and your body goes
yeah
off and i'm yeah i'm not speaking this
into your life okay i hear this often
that
people who struggle with attention
issues with adhd with some sort of
i'll just say that with the 80d world
there can be a ping-pong relationally
whether it's with multiple partners
multiple people multiple relationships
depth of relationship because there's
something about connection with somebody
else that makes everything go all right
we're okay
and it's a brain trying to solve for
connection
desperately
and
some people solve for connection through
perfectionism i will score my way into
your heart
i will prove or earn my way
into
good relationship with you
the same exact thing just the other side
of the equation
is
i will burn this down so you will see me
drugs
help am i is it ringing true what i'm
saying maybe not
yeah i'm definitely more of the i will
score my way into someone else's heart
type person gotcha and so when if you're
if and i'm the same so i got two phds
not because i'm smart but because i was
on this continual treadmill to prove to
the world and to myself and to a few
people who didn't know i was trying to
prove myself to them
that i was capable and smart and blah
blah this was
i mean now i'm celebrated for it i got a
job because of it but it was purely
running tactics for me
and
it was chasing chasing chasing and it's
when i was able to settle into an actual
relationship and by the way i was
married for 10 years before i figured
this out
really and then i had to practice what
does being in a relationship mean
not that my marriage is fine
i didn't know how to accept love i did
not accept peace i didn't know how to
accept calm i didn't know what that was
and calm felt like quitting calm felt
like less than peace felt like well you
could be doing this
and so i was always spun up and so then
my body has to adjust and over toggle
and when things get complex it goes we
gone we out
that is exactly what i'm experiencing
and the loop never stops in fact the
loop gets tighter and tighter because my
guess is when you're up and you're on
you outwork everybody around you is that
fair
yeah when i'm really on i'm a hundred
percent unstoppable
yes yeah and you get more done in those
times that everybody else does and so
when you fall off um you're able to duct
tape it together get it across or just
be like hey i need an extension on this
whatever until you can find up the
gumption to white knuckle a thing and
get it done
i'm having a hard time getting back up
at the moment i think that's exactly
right because then you run into
something like i don't know like a
pandemic for a few years and your body
just goes hey how about this we're done
i'm out right
i'm out yeah i started this job during
the pandemic and that was very difficult
for me yes yes because your body's
trying to deal with all the other
threats too
yeah
so i'm gonna tell you the few things
that have worked in my life and they are
hard and they are annoying okay
okay some of it is coming to truth and
and peace
with
the stories i was born into
meaning
my mom and dad are two extraordinary
people
and i'm gonna do some things differently
with my kids
and i had to own that gap
i had to go back and figure out what is
my six-year-old self still trying to
solve
and it's almost always it's a worthiness
in relationship issue
yeah and so there's a season of anger
towards your parents or your brother and
sister or towards your teachers or
whatever there's a sing a season of
shame i can't believe i let that whatev
and then you hopefully get to a season
of peace which is dude there was people
just loving me the best way they could
with the tools they had it's incredible
i'm so grateful
i've came i've um come around to it um
with the help of my therapist and she's
been absolutely monumental in that
awesome awesome
so then the next things were the things
that you mentioned diet exercise
community other people
often adhd folks
don't like to be in community other
people because they can't control the
interactions
and it's when i started making time to
be with friends even though it didn't
feel like productive time it was just be
when i made the switch in my head being
with my friends watching the fights for
four hours just sitting on chairs
running our mouths and talking crap
about nothing
that's productive time for my body is
when my body went alright cool let's do
that then i had to make peace with it
is that hard for you or do you like that
do you like more one-on-one interactions
or do you like
the life of the party
it depends
it really depends
yeah yes when your body's exhausted when
it's not i love it we're basically the
same human except you're cooler than me
because your name's from the bible not
after a toilet it's awesome
um
sleep has become the main player in my
life
sleep sugar and screen time are the
three major players in my life
if i go a couple of days with no screens
i find my ability to plug in and be on
task to be
10x what it normally is one quick
question about that okay um
how do you do that when you're a
computer animator
you build in on time and off time
okay
and unfortunately for a computer com
computer animator
your downtime can't be the office
it has to be nature okay
okay and
that i you're downtown
today i'm into outdoor sports too yes
yes yes so your down time will be i've
got to always have a season of something
okay
and leaning into nature that's the other
one that get that the research keeps
coming back saying that people who go
out into nature it begins they call them
nature baths now they he it heals you
i'll spend time hiking in the woods not
even in an urban setting if i can
um i'll go on hike trails or walk trails
or whatever and i won't have a podcast
in i'm going to let my brain and body
rest
because it's so spun up and i'm gonna
double down triple drought quadruple
down on connection and connection not
for my value with somebody else
but connection and learning to receive
the fact that i'm okay
i'm an all right guy
one of the great moments i had in
therapy
i walked out of a session and i felt
a hundred pounds lighter and the words
that came into my head were
oh my gosh i don't suck like i'm not a
piece of crap
and i don't know where i got that from
my parents never told me that my
community never told me
i just over time had
piled that one up
i'm that's exactly how i feel too
nobody's ever told me that i'm a piece
of crap but i've always thought that i
was and often that comes from oh you got
a 93
wow you only missed one huh if you'd
gotten one more right it would have been
a
hundred
or man you look so good in that dress if
you lost five pounds you would be a
supermodel
or
oh you're making forty eight thousand a
year man
you gotta like man next time make sure
you negotiate better so you can get 55.
and it's not that somebody says you suck
they just move the carrot on you every
single time
yeah
is that fair
yeah that's very fair and what i want
you to to come to terms with come to
peace with is
i'm all right i have value that doesn't
mean you don't live a disciplined life
adhd people have to have a highly highly
disciplined life
highly disciplined life if i don't
exercise the rest of my day falls apart
i know that
i just know it and i hate it it sucks
it's my life though and i've made peace
with my life
and there are days when i have to get
this book done i just finished a
manuscript and got it sent in
the last two weeks
was some of the two of the hardest weeks
of my life it was a
absolute mind-numbing grind i was angry
i sent emails i probably shouldn't i
mean i was just angry all the time
and i have to i know now my family knows
i know my friends know my co-workers
know uh we're entering that season i let
people know i'm not gonna be fun to be
around for the next two weeks because i
gotta finish this thing and i gotta push
through
and
there is seasons when that that's just
part of life for us
but it's not always
okay do you feel like you're gonna quit
get fired from your job
no but it's it's a fear that keeps me up
at night there you go um that's actually
now when that's like i'm struggling to
learn yes that's anxiety
so you have permission to learn you have
permission to ask questions you have
permission to say i don't understand
this can you help me
and that is not an indicator that you're
dumb or that you don't have character
that means you need to learn different
ways and somehow for most of us that
stuff got jumbled up
if you don't get this grade on this test
you're an idiot
and if you're an idiot i love you less
or if ida can't learn a thing as fast as
that guy on that computer over there
then he's gonna get the raise i'm not
gonna get the raise and then suddenly
i'm five years into the future where i'm
fired and homeless
yeah that's exactly where my brain goes
that's anxiety
okay okay i'm gonna send you a free copy
of my book redefining anxiety okay it's
really short
and it clears it up really quick and if
you want how about this i'm gonna send
you two and i want you to take one of
your accounts and y'all can read it
together okay that sounds fantastic
thank you so much you got so stay on the
line and jenna's gonna get you a copy of
it actually jenna's back austin left in
the middle of the show by the way the
people who are listening
um jen is back and i want you to read
that book it's real short you can read
it in like an afternoon
and then i want you to go oh
i believe i don't have any data that i
believe that adhd is on the anxiety
trend line
it's a body's response to chaos that
turns into
every alarm bell we got ringing at every
time and most of our alarms ring because
we're disconnected from relationships
i wish it was more complex than that
now okay you solve for a relationship
you solve for peace you solve for the
anxiety
and you make peace with the fact that
your brain is supercharged
i consider adhd my superpower
let me put it this way we got into some
editorial disc like debates here in the
office i took a week off of work and
wrote 81 000 words i started over from
the very beginning of the book in five
days
wow that's a supercharged brain that's
my superpower and my family left the
state
they went to texas they're like we're
gonna let you do this on your own
because it's not gonna be a pretty sight
around here
and
so i made i've made peace with it my
family's made peace with it we got it
done it was brutal it was hard
and then
jennifer who's the editor on this book
with me
oh gosh that she
when she dies she's just on an express
lane to the afterlife she'll just
they'll wave her in because of this one
season she's such a saint
um
but
i know that and so i'm gonna treat
people kindly with dignity and i know
i'm gonna have seasons where i just have
to grind something out and it's awful
and it sucks i gotta do it i gotta do it
again i gotta do it again and i'm not
happy and i hate it it's driving me
crazy and there's gonna be days when
this is my superpower and i can outwork
everybody
all of that starts with loving yourself
in relationship
thank you so so much for the call just
so you know your bravery just speaking
this out loud is gonna help a whole
whole bunch of people i'm grateful for
you
thank you cool stay on the line and
we'll get your information we'll get you
the book sent out all right thank you so
so much for your call